I just want to ask you to elaborate on
the monetary policy aspect right now we
we're seeing eggs at six dollars for for
a dozen we're seeing uh you know uh
Banks going insolvent can you explain
what this economic system is what's
wrong with it
well uh the the main reason is is uh you
don't have
of the unit
because if you were building a building
and you were an architect you'd want a
unit of account or a unit of a
measurement uh how are we going to
measure all these things are we going to
do it in feet yards or whatever because
everything has to be measured in
economics you have to have a unit of
account and that of course is a defined
currency and they can get away with you
know we're messing it up for long
periods of time we were able to get away
with destroying the unit of account you
know all the way back in 1934 and 1971
the way it is now but we were very very
wealthy and we still are wealthy but
we're getting poorer because people rely
on debt and the debt is growing and uh
the the price inflation is moving along
and uh it's a consequence that they've
destroyed them one of the most important
items the most important price in
economics is the price of money how much
it takes to borrow what was it minus for
a couple years and during that time the
FED would come up and said oh oh you
know we're having trouble we we want we
want the inflation the price inflation
we want the destruction of the value of
money go at two percent a year and it's
down to minus one or minus two this is
the craziest thing in the world the last
the last thing they they should be doing
but now and I said you know when it
finally gets to two percent you wait you
won't even see it it'll be ten percent
after that and uh and and now that's
because there's the uh there's the
theory of subjective theory of value
that tells you that you can't make those
predictions but you can make predictions
that if you mess up with the uh monetary
system run up debt it all this debt has
to be liquidated and we are in the
middle of defaulting on that money and
that is going that is the crisis we face
and right now we're not very far along
at accepting what we have to accept if
we want to crawl our way out of here and
get back to being a productive Nation do
you think I just I just want to go back
a little bit but what you said before
this statement because I think this is
what really is important about your
message A lot of people are like what
politician is going to save me and in
reality no politician is going to save
you personal responsibility is extremely
important what's happening with the big
Banks what's happening with the ESG
score the international multinational
corporations running things is far more
important especially when it comes to
your own individual
decisions that you make in everyday life
and I think this is why that message is
so much more important because
everyone's like please someone save us
in reality the only person who's going
to save you is you yourself and and you
know you've taken many steps
homeschooling you opened up a
homeschooling Network as well can you
tell us how that is going and how people
could potentially be involved in that
well it's the Ron Paul Curriculum you
just get on the website there and the
school did has done it steady and does
well but there was a big big burst of
interest you know during covet but some
of the people went back to the
government schools you know after that
so uh I I think that uh peop people will
respond and that's why the important
thing is to keep things legal so that we
can do that and that's why the internet
is so important it can be be a destroyer
or it could be our savior I mean we do
our program you know on the Internet
it's where we do it we get a programs
like this out so that that is uh and
every once in a while I'll see something
I've always thought oh the Libertarians
will take care of that there's a lot of
smart people they know this and when the
government comes in and takes over the
Internet they will have competition and
I think we're getting it and uh and it's
just a little bit slow in doing it but I
I think as long as you have some Freedom
there and can use it but that's why
we're in such a threatening period
because they're destroying our first
amendment rights you know people are
getting punished for this they lose
their jobs I knew doctors that you know
I'm taking care of patients and they say
and they might have you know their
livelihood and they say well if you
don't get your shot you know you're
you're going to lose your hospital
position if uh your hospital
privileges that that is really wicked
stuff so that that protecting the first
amendment is one of our biggest
challenges right now yeah I think the
way the First Amendment translates to
the internet is software code we need
the access to our software code so we
can see if it's spying on us or if it's
feeding us Mal information algorithms
it's going to be like something an
amendment maybe to the Constitution to
well guarantee of Freedom let me let me
break that down and actually ask you Dr
Paul what uh Ian brings up a great point
when you're on Facebook when you're on
Twitter they're choosing what you see to
manipulate what you think so how can we
have free speech if these big
corporations are only letting us see see
one thing well you can't and I'll be the
first one to tell you the technology uh
I don't understand a lot of it but I
want it to be free and to make make
these decisions elsewhere but uh no the
big thing is and uh you know Jonathan
Turley has done such a great job to
exposing this the line has to be drawn
in and I bet you there are a lot of
Libertarians at the beginning of this I
always thought well these companies are
private they can do what they want if
we're not going to close them down and
but there is an answer for that they're
not private and early on I said they're
nothing but the arm of the government
and uh and and that's a big difference
and then all of a sudden we got the
proof of that but that came out now not
many people are talking about it but the
FBI and the CIA they work with these uh
these uh these companies like all the
social welfare so social companies well
that that is a that is a big deal and
that could be stopped that's that should
uh it should be uh you know a a violent
act to do that especially when the
government's here that's why we should
have a lot less government yes and they
did it from the very beginning
especially with companies like nqutel
especially with a lot of the seed
funding especially with a lot of the
advancement that government gave
companies like Google alphabet to the
advantage over their competitors and I
saw a lot of people argue you know even
just a couple years ago being like these
companies are private companies they
could do what they want we have to
standby capitals I'm like you guys
aren't even paying attention to what's
really going on here because as you said
they are arms of the state they are
acting for their own best interest and
they're sowing division in this country
creating order out of chaos to
specifically create a situation where we
are fighting each other over Petty
differences rather than actually looking
at the true source of our problem and
that's the dollar being the valued
that's our currency just being thrown
away and our whole livelihoods just
being taken away from us which is
absolutely crazy do you think it would
be righteous to default on the interest
of the Federal Reserve
oh
uh yeah I think if I could write a pen
and close down the Federal Reserve I
just would and everybody has to scatter
what would what would be like the
evolution of our monetary system how
what's a better system but I wouldn't do
that I you know I I guess if I I say the
most important thing if you want to act
in a is a somewhat gradual system
because you're not going to do that
you're not going to do it because if you
cut the FED off uh the the whole thing
crashes and they'll be revolutions and
all this so I I I started with uh
getting more information that's why I
concentrate on auditing the FED find out
what they're doing and the one thing
over the many years that I've worked on
this that is the most uh important uh
information that they hang on to and
that is their transactions with foreign
governments that is that is really
sacred and uh they uh they don't want
that to happen I've been told that they
work with the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland and like the
bank of London the bank of Australia and
the New York Federal Reserve are like
they all send money through this Swiss
bank yeah that's right it's a bank for
the central banks and I guess they have
to park some of their money in places
but it's the nature of the monetary
system see if uh prior to uh Central
Banking which was uh you know the debate
started with our Revolution with
Jefferson and Hamilton you know there
was no they weren't discussing the bank
of international settlements back back
then so it's uh it's it's totally
unnecessary in a free market the most
important thing is Define the currency
by weight or something real and uh then
uh the the then prohibiting anybody from
disobeying it the Constitution is pretty
clear on it and to some of the states
now are reacting to this states are
coming through and trying to develop
their own own currency because it's
tough for them to say well you know the
state's uh states can only use uh you
know gold and silver as legal tender now
my bill in Congress was a little bit
more generalized it said repeal all the
laws all the monopoly laws that the
government has and control and let the
market decide it but if the founder said
no uh even the states can't just print
up their own money but I think in a free
Society a Libertarian Society you could
have contracts if you're setting up a
bank and you say this is the unit of
account and they say and you're going to
use gold you have to live up to your
contract it seems like crypto is the new
contract which is data like what's the
account symbol it's how much work was
done to produce the Bitcoin or whatever
so you can see on a on a database well
there's this much computer power used
well yeah and that gets a little more
complex because if you say uh what is
what's behind goal you know everybody
knows gold they've used it for five
thousand years so people know what what
it is but it's always been gold didn't
be didn't fall out of the sky and become
money goldfell came out of the ground
and was pretty
and they used it you know jewelry and it
valued and all the important things of
money that that happened then it became
very practical to be used as money but
you might find uh you might find 20
things and more all the time there's
there's actually things uh uh being
Advanced now even when I was in medical
school we studied about there was some
arthritis that uh that could be treated
with gold and silver gold especially and
there's more and more Silver's been used
as a medication and so it should be
legalized for that reason but that's
what helps make it money that isn't that
you're using money to do that it means
that is what makes it money I don't
think you could make the same argument
with a crypto what are you going to say
to we've created a crypto coin because
we used to use this in medicine
well let me let me I wanted it I want to
say this I think because of you Dr Paul
you you made a lot of people
Millionaires and billionaires because
when your message was going around about
the US dollar being unsound based on
these policies there were a lot of
people that were trying to figure out
what they could do to store their value
properly of course gold and silver were
big but when Bitcoin emerged a whole
bunch of Libertarians and people who had
heard your message said I'm gonna check
this thing out
and they bought a bunch and 10 years
later there were 300 400 million dollars
because governments all over the world
are buying crypto and trying to use it
many people have have decided for
whatever reason it has value to them and
the early adopters who were paying
attention to the problems of the US
dollar they got to rise along with it
so what does that prove I don't know if
proves anything I just think like if
they listen to you for whatever reason
they ended up becoming very well yeah
but the one thing for sure I wasn't
giving uh investment advice right no I
mean it turns out it's okay but I might
have been talking about agriculture yeah
you could go out and buy land Jimmy
Rogers oh yeah that's what we should do
about and and that serves that function
but I think that that's a little bit
different uh I I the way I answer those
questions is uh you know does that mean
you want to be cautious and make some
rules about about Bitcoin no I'd let the
market decide whether people really want
Bitcoin or not uh and and uh they they
uh I was I go to a lot of uh Bitcoin
crypto meetings and things especially
early on and at these meetings I became
a little bit nervous because they had
one individual there that they were
hovering around and these are the people
that was running the conference they
were hovering around this woman that
said oh she had had experience with
Washington DC as a lobbyist in ways and
means and will protect you when they
start writing the laws about and I
thought
no you don't need you
that's that's not my my way of looking
at it I mean if if it's designed mainly
to prevent fraud or something like that
you have to be able to but I I just
think that you don't need laws uh you
know to tell people uh how to protect
against gold what concerns me about
tying money to a hard thing like gold is
that someone can steal all the gold
like if we tie it to anything then that
thing can be taken and hoarded by
someone
maybe maybe but they've uh you know the
the uh uh they see the the silver people
back in the 70s uh Hunt Brothers they
cornered the market and they took it up
when silver was five dollars or three
dollars they took it up to fifty dollars
they were hoarding it wow but the market
came along and took care but real quick
Ian bitcoin's been stolen tons of times
it just it happens all the time yeah
they find ways and right now gold is at
an all-time high Bitcoin just hit above
30 000 today as well uh and I remember
doing my coverage of currency collapses
in Venezuela and in Zimbabwe and we were
talking about this a little bit before
the show before our currency kind of
collapses a lot of different things
happened before it does there's many
things that happen in many different
years and then all of a sudden when it
drops it drops quickly and the effects
are one by one by one by one and and and
it goes by so fast people are shocked
and surprised do you think that is
possible in the United States do you see
a possible currency collapse and
potentially on what kind of time scale
now I don't think it's possible it's
going to be it's going to happen
inevitable so it will it because they
can't keep uh keep doing this but uh you
know you mentioned that uh you know some
of those people that took my advice I
wonder if they're going to give me a cut
on what they make you know no it just
happened that uh it was an alternative
and so far the alternative has made a
lot of people rich but do you think
there were 10 people 100 people 5 000
people or or a million people that
bought that bought cryptocurrency or
crypto between 30 and 68.
and it's on the way up and then on the
way down there's a lot of buying it's
hell and so so it is some people make a
log but but the whole thing is is I want
a definition I mean you could they can
do it it would be legal as long as
there's no fraud involved but it you
still have to have a definition I can
define
a uh a gold dollar and for us it was uh
it was not rounded off but you know at
the time of the Constitution they had a
precise weight of silver which was the
real monetary issue but it uh it was the
the gold was at uh you know 42 dollars
an ounce you know and uh you know 26 22
26 dollars an hour and that would stay
there for a long long time and but that
didn't prove anything other than we had
a lot of gold and we would it's sort of
like the uh the Romans did they they had
Advanced their that they'd Advanced
their uh Kingdom and and uh and go out
and steal all the gold from the people
and uh in a way we have advanced you
know our Empire and we have become very
wealthy but now we're consuming it we're
consuming it so definitions will change
according to that but you still know uh
you know it was twenty dollars an ounce
and then it went to thirty five dollars
an ounce cheated the American people
total fraud and then it was released in
71 and it went to 800 an ounce then it
had to be the market adjusting and
that's a benefit the market will sort
that out but uh but the definition is
gone my argument is you have to have a
definition if you want to have a sound
economy and the world has never been on
a Fiat currency to the extent that we're
uh that we have now with the with the
paper money dollar thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time